vous prétendez être un bon comédien vous
ont tabassé ce que les autres disent les
bagarres et autres personnes que tu ne
connais pas faire dit il
tu t'es pris 40 râteau par luc besson
gastambide tout le monde tu as tes jeux
de croix paraître je crois pas je suis
mauvais temps le permet d'essayer des
jarres être animateur et vous reviendrez
[Applaudissements]
nous avons la chance mathieu est la plus
drôle des telenovelas c'est l'émission
de gilles sur cnued ce que vous
prétendez que médian nation d'avoir une
vraie communion plateau parce que parce
que parce qu'elle a fait un film we did
entraîner des gains excusez du peu
[Musique]
elle est actrice vous on va se rendre
compte maintenant un géant j'ai en face
de moi le dialogue qu'on a vu de cet
excédent de telenovelas entre deux cas
entre deux caractères je vais remettre
les images si on peut le voir vous
puissiez vous imprégner du personnel
personnages leur silence non seulement
vous appréciez mais restituer sur ce
plateau cette scène ouais voilà on sort
on sera donc jugé que vous me demandez
là s'est demandée approche de ne
conduire une renault modus a alors
commencé à conduire un kart et pendant
ce temps là tu me fais ça wilson calme
toi car ils ne touchent pas menteur que
tu es tu veux encore me dire que ta
relation avec cette fille n'était pas
sérieuse et que tu ne lui a jamais
promis le mariage
je n'ai jamais voulu en gros c'est cette
fille
crois moi c'est la vérité
tu ne veux pas en gros c'est une fille
et tu as des rapports sexuels avec elle
sont de protéger c'est crédible ça quand
ça vient d'un intellectuel comme toi
[ __ ] et un bon mondial
on n'est pas naïf on n'est pas l'abri du
prochain budget pour la gestuelle
imaginée à mettre d un casteur nous
regarde derrière du coup j'ai pris pour
un film je quitte ses huit syriens tout
ça bien fou tout le monde dans la mer
des élites uvale ridiculiser relève
journée m
le thème j'aime beaucoup de la vente est
pourquoi tu me fais ça oui ça nous le
toit caroline moteur que tu es tu veux
encore me dire que la relation avec
cette fille n'était pas sérieuse et que
tu n'y a jamais promis le mariage tu
veux mais ce qu'est venu à te faire un
enfant
alors que les panais comme épouse
mais quand on applaudit on parle pas du
sud n'était au courant de rien caroline
ce n'est pas moi qu'il a un gros c'est
cette fille et crois moi c'est la vérité
tu ne veux pas en gros si cette fille
alors et mais tu as des rapports sexuels
avec elle comprend pas s'il met le doigt
sur la tempe
c'est toi qui menait sa médiane à la
comédienne a réclamé mon texte table
c'est crédible ça quand ça vient d'un
acteur tel comme toi est-ce que juste
rejouer mois la fin de la semaine
c'est incroyable elle vient faire là bas
les classes sait pas aller le classe
nous paraît tout de leurs mots qu'elle a
giflé n'est pas une famille française
échelon
merci alors bon il était très bon et
kelly très déceptif mais non mais
l'engrais pour pouvoir lire sont pas
bien ouais on ne touche pas aux lycées
marilyn monroe est là lui actuellement
mais le problème c'est un défi ni
franchement qu'elle est une actrice mais
voilà senna mourani